it has been nearly a month now since the
u.s food and drug administration issued
an alert which some nevada health
workers had already warned them about
covet antigen tests are prone to giving
false positive
denise valdez now joining us with
today's health watch denise
well hi there brian so how reliable are
these rapid tests that thousands of
people are getting
first let's start with the two standard
diagnostic tests and they are actually
quite different
first the molecular or the pcr now it's
pretty accurate
it's a lab-based test that can take days
to process and get the results
the test detects the viruses genetic
material
then the other is the antigen it's a
quick right on the spot test that's less
sensitive than the pcr
but it's pretty good at identifying
people who are at or near
peak infection now unlike those lab
based molecular pcr tests
they detect snippets of the viruses
material and
are less sensitive and they can detect
samples with a high viral load
now the tests were validated for people
with copin 19 symptoms
pretty much in the first week of
symptoms now in that scenario
they're pretty darn accurate but it's
trickier when it comes to asymptomatic
screenings
in fact about 40 percent of infections
are spread
by asymptomatic people with a high viral
load
so antigen tests even though they might
be a little imperfect
they shouldn't be dismissed dr kathleen
winston who is the dean for college of
nursing at university of phoenix
maintains widespread antigen testing is
still the key to curb the spread
you have to have a certain level of
virus in your bloodstream
in order for a diagnostic test to be
accurate so
again the the test that we're looking
for current infection
that's what the that's the measure of
the accuracy of that test
so if i have a high viral load i have
the the
nasopharyngeal swab test for the virus
then that will give me a
more closely correct and accurate
positive diagnosis
now depending on the quality of the
antigen test and also the test takers
false negatives could be as high as 20
percent
now the concern is false positives could
be caused by the presence of other
viruses
maybe they weren't collected properly or
even sometimes the swabs
may not have been stored at the proper
temperature still though
antigen testing technology continues to
improve and you should get tested if you
feel sick